Dimitri pescott for who uh who lies
fairly routinely uh in his job as uh
Kremlin spokesperson has said today that
the the drones we're seeing that clearly
looked like Iranian drones uh that are
bringing such destruction and Terror uh
in the Skies over Ukraine he says they
are they're not uh Iranian he says we
have no information about that he says
that Russia is using Russian Hardware
with Russian names and the Iranians also
are denying their supplying these drones
whereas the minister of defense and
Western intelligence agencies and other
observers are in no doubt at all that
what we're seeing uh over Ukraine is the
Shaheed 136 being deployed that the
Russians have either bought or been
supplied by the Iranians uh and this is
what's called a loitering munition which
means it can fly around uh for a while
for an app few hours or so I think and
then choose a Target and then come down
and blow it up and what we've seen from
the videos of these attacks over the
last 24 to 48 hours is that they can
cause massive explosions these videos
show civilians screaming with with Tara
as these uh drones come in and that
cause a kind of mushroom cloud of smoke
and dust and debris they've been
nicknamed Kamikaze drones but um they
are I think more akin to sort of the
World War II V1 or V2 Doodle Bug rockets
that cause such fear in the the the ends
of the the second world war because
londoners could hear them above and
droning overhead and that would cause
fear as they try to work out where they
were coming to land well it's very
similar with the Shaheed 136 the
Russians have renamed it the geranium II
for some reason
um they're naming it after a flower but
as I say analysts are in no doubt it is
is Iranian the reasons the Iranians are
doubting it's something to do with the
the nuclear deal in 2015 that the French
and the British have worn them they
could be in breach of and therefore they
may uh impose further sanctions in the
light of that deal if the Iranians are
breaching that deal by supplying uh
these drones I think if you're on the
ground in Ukraine it doesn't really
matter what it's called or where it's
coming from it is causing havoc and the
Ukrainian President says that 30 percent
of Ukraine's power infrastructure has
been destroyed by these kinds of attacks
and what the Russians have said today
peskov saying that the Russians are
targeting military infrastructure but
also energy infrastructure as well so an
admission by the Russians that they are
going after Ukraine's power uh
capability uh the electricity Supply
ahead of winter and I think the
suspicion is that having failed
militarily so far they are trying to
bomb the ukrainians into submission by
freezing them effectively ahead of
winter if a third of their power supply
has already been destroyed according to
ukrainians then then that could be
fairly disastrous for ukrainians if a
lot more of it is destroyed in the
coming weeks um but the Russians are
admitting that they are attacking these
effectively civilian facilities saying
that's part of their special military
operation peskov also said today that
the areas of the east of Ukraine that
Russia has illegally annexed and
annexation not recognized by anywhere
anyone else and that was condemned by
overwhelming majority in the United
Nations he says those lands are regarded
now as an inalienable part of Russia and
fall under the protection of Russia's
nuclear
umbrella now we have heard other
officials the foreign minister Sergey
lavrov saying that the the rhetoric
around uh the nuclear threat has been
overheated and should be toned down he
said that in recent days well peskov is
is talking about it again saying that
implying that all this land that Russia
has illegally seized could be to be
protected by Russia's nuclear deterrence
so not lowering the temperature at all
neither